what's up everybody i am on the road
right now these are my july dates it's
vegas phoenix and boulder colorado on
the july 15 16 and 17 and then i'm in
portland syracuse and vancouver on july
20 21 and 22. all of those are on sale
right now at savile candlecomedy.com as
well as about 15 new cities that start
from october to january check it out
right now i hope to see you guys on the
road
hey baby go to
chrisdcomedy.com i am in montreal at the
end of july i am in burlington vermont
and i got bray improv in august and we
got san francisco in september and we
got chicago theater in september we got
more dates coming soon but montreal and
vermont on sale now july 27th and 29th
chrisdcomedy.com for tiki wiki's also my
special special she out on
[Music]
to say hey netflix
hey babe hey i gotta go back i'm going
to sicily see
you guys right away two weeks i got i'm
we're we're booking it right now today
you're leaving when in two weeks for
assistance that's the best way to do it
just so you're just you're booking a
book that trip right now right we
literally are booking it as i said we
talked about this last night you just
booked a hotel like day of yeah that's
that's the best way to do it day off
what else am i going to do why not this
is all the pod we'll do the song at the
end yeah this is this this is the best i
booked a hotel sal last night was so
confused that i didn't have a hotel i
booked the hotel on the way to the hotel
on the way to hotel i did it today bro
that's the best way to live what if it's
sold out never not going to be you don't
worry about it i'm telling you not for
me yeah you know what the guy said hey
are you are you on dave i go yeah and he
goes you're andrew santino yeah he goes
[__] oh awesome i go thanks man he's
like oh so thanks man
and then i go all right he gives me the
room key and i go to the elevator
because miss santino um hold on he's
getting you an upgrade and i was like oh
you don't have to do that ah
that's what it is love it thanks a
little bit of an upgrade no but you but
i always book day off dude that is the
best way so so i've talked about this on
the road you can't risk that no yes you
can go on hotel tonight that out not
their sponsor but but but that app hotel
tonight i found some of the best like
ritz carlton level hotels night of for
half the price because their rooms just
go to waste so they put them on these
there's other apps too there's a ton of
them yeah you go but that's the way i'm
telling you the less you plan your
vacations the more fun you have always
the less itinerary i'm sorry i'm telling
you
you need to
i need a landing destination no no that
that for sure here's what you do you
gotta just get on a plane and land and
be like what hotels are around you know
what i like to do how about this if i'm
going out of the country
you booked a hotel for the first night
then you have that day to figure out
where where you're gonna go next and if
you need to stay in that hotel another
night you tell them we're gonna stay
another night and if they say we're all
booked no you're not
um and it works yeah they go oh you're
right maybe we're not wow let me tell
you something hotels are never 100 book
that is impossible unless it's like the
final four then uh
and also with hotels if you there's a
whole department that people don't know
if you literally now don't take
advantage of it but like if you have any
problem at all with your room and you go
at the end and they say how are you
saying you'd say well i had a problem
with you know the sink didn't work once
they will take money off your charge oh
yeah so i i i i went to syracuse this
weekend rocks i didn't want to stay in
rochester i'm like i'll go to syracuse
i'll sleep two nights and seasons so
they invented the shot clock
it is i saw it yeah i saw the shot clock
there so i get to the hotel it was uh
well we won't i won't say what hotel so
we're checking them out you're not in
yeah because i i went from rochester and
i drove day after the show i went to go
check in at about 11 p.m and i walked up
to my room and it was the most
disgusting hotel there was a bug in the
sink i took all these pictures uh there
that was the whole entire room was a
double bed it was about a hundred square
feet how much was that a night it was
out 249.99 outside my door a toilet
plunger outside my door did you sit on
it i i you got to sit down you got to
sit on it you got to try it
it's too inviting this was the blankets
just tossed in a ball in the corner and
the thing and i was like i'm not there
was water all over the bathroom floor
can we send the video off the pimp and
he puts it on the pod yeah
yeah the guy that was living in that
room had to get out fast
look the toilet paper was like down like
it was like it was huge like yeah
and i i walk downstairs i'm like excuse
me i was like uh do you have any other
rooms whatsoever and she's like why and
i was like well because i just went
upstairs and there's water on the floor
there's a bug in the sink the toilet
paper was used to plunge outside the
door and you know this room is just
disgusting she's like did you sit on the
planet she goes when did you when did
you when did you check in i go i just
checked in i
i go my backpack is on right she goes i
didn't see you and i i started at 11. i
said well there was the other girl and
she goes well it's 11 20. i said so i
had 20 minutes i said i was upstairs i
was upstairs aghast for 20 minutes
it was this was in the closet
you're never gonna you're never fully
dressed without a smile
look at the window can i say something
yes please look at this look that was on
the windows here what is that oh man
this is what are you doing sleeping in a
stop this is what this is what syracuse
had to offer that was that does not that
looks like a [__] it's what syracuse
had to offer and it was it looked like
that's a motel with an m and so i said
all that's the name of the episode what
does syracuse have to offer
so i went on hotels tonight i downloaded
the app that minute i sort of got it i'd
use it two nights ago and everything was
freaking sold out no and really and and
and recall we were calling all the
hotels and aloft was around i was like
yeah i was like that's what i had to do
and i called and they said it was sold
out and then we went on to the internet
and there was two rooms left and they
told us on the phone it was [__] sold
out so you got the rooms at the end so
i'm just i'm just corroborating
what i said which is a little something
that they say they can't do and they can
do it they never sold out they're never
sold out my mother taught me this what
one of the most
fun things you can do
fine if you don't want to get on a plane
fine but just that day let's say you
have an off day i've actually done this
twice in my life and both times was the
best some of the best things that ever
happened to me once i had nothing to do
like zero to do my mother used to do
this with me when i was a kid we just
got on i just got on amtrak and i went
to washington dc and i went around
washington dc for the day because my mom
used to do that with me all the time
whereas oh what do you want to do today
honey uh i don't know she's like all
right we're gonna get on a train we're
gonna go to boston and then it's like
she's like you got 10 minutes to pack
your bag and then i'm like
it's crazy like like on wednesday my
kids are gonna wake up and we're just
gonna take him to hershey park this [__]
i learned from my mom just gonna take
him to hershey park no hotel book
nothing we're just gonna go to the
amusement park buy the tickets and then
we figure it out because i think this is
the thing you have to do with kids is
you cannot plan your day because they
are not going to want to do what you
want to do instead you have to be open
and accept it when me and which is
something you should do with people's
sexuality chris which is what i'm trying
to do
you need to work because i felt like
genuinely i was going to come out
tonight to my family and then you told
me that i still got a pouch and i can't
do that pouch i said he didn't say i
said loaf yeah a little loaf there but
but
so and then one time i think i've told
this story before so you don't book
anything because you know that your kids
are not going to go for it or you don't
book anything because you're like the
heir of spontaneity sometimes i book
stuff but sometimes i like to go to the
air spontaneity yeah um so so also also
also i mean i don't know if i haven't
seen me but bubs you got i mean it's
you you don't really i promise it's in
there you think i'm just gonna go to
hershey park without booking a hotel
yeah no you will yeah you will yeah you
will yeah you won't i'll stay at seoul
richardson's house okay so
so one time i went we had the weekends
mixed up when i was co-parenting we had
the weekends mixed up and i thought it
was my weekend to take my daughter so i
didn't have any shows booked out it was
just going to be me and my kid we're
going to do something i go to the house
they're like no she's
delilah's mom my girl's like
i'm taking her away to the poconos or
something so now i have a free weekend
no shows and i hate the heat like i
despise it i know that august
98 degrees pure humidity new york city i
was like i hate it what i love is the
rain and the cold so shout out nick
lachey shout out nick lachey so i uh
shut out cincinnati so handsome the
hottest one and drew the shades hotter
uh uh so true [__] came on late though
he did come on late but she had the
shine in the beginning then drew took it
at the dance with the stars continue
fair yeah so i
so i said i looked at my phone that day
i went home to my apartment i said i
kind of thought of my mom what would she
always say pack a book bag in 10 minutes
so i packed a book bag in 10 minutes was
your mom in the movie heat
no okay she does look like val kilmer
though my mom
so i said i want to go somewhere that
where it's rainy and cold that's just
what makes me happy i'm not gonna see my
kid anyway i'm sad i'm not gonna see my
kid i have no shows so now and my kids
not coming home till monday night it was
friday morning so i'm like i got time
here right so i went
i looked at weather wow where is it
raining where's it called edinboro
scotland 55 degrees rainy for that
weekend
that i went to
american airlines app booked a flight to
edinboro business class and i booked it
and the flight actually wasn't as
expensive as it was because they weren't
selling the tickets so sometimes you get
lucky and airline prices actually go
down if you go as late as i went because
the flight was in like three hours so
like i got there just you know
internationally you have to get like
check in two hours before like i was at
the last moments and i got in and i went
to edinburgh i did not book my hotel in
edinburgh scotland until i was in the
middle of the atlantic ocean got while i
find the plane and then booked the hotel
and i had the best time ever is that
they call that flying by the city of
pants i think that literally what i was
doing i was flying by the seat of my
pants and i went there with
just underwear socks and one pair of
pants and one sweatshirt because i was
like now what was the strategy there
because i'm like because what i like now
with traveling it's like i got to bring
100 pairs of shoes it's all stressful
but now you land and you have to spend
valuable
scotland time going to buy underwear no
i had underwear and socks as long as i
have underwear and socks i said what how
dirty are someone's pants really going
to get right how dirty is your
sweatshirt really can get that's another
tip my mom would always say is travel
light pack light always travel light if
traveling with just a book bag the
amount of stress it drops is insane i
don't get on the plane i don't care
about your overhead space i don't care
about your overhead space yeah i got a
carry-on that's all i got i don't care
about it i got a foot bag yeah i don't
need to i don't need the overhead space
take it put your [__] kid up there i
don't give a [__] you [__] that's
unbelievable but that is a long flight
to book though for just you have to be
home by when monday i be home by monday
but when you're coming back from europe
i left monday at 12 i got home monday at
like 3 p.m because you get six hours
back and was it a good trip
are you kidding me the best trip i had a
great as a matter of fact i because i
knew my kid's mom would be mad at me i
did a facetime with my daughter from my
hotel room she thought i was home i was
in edinburgh scotland
like harry potter running around like
[__] harry potter wow you do anything
like that no he's a [__] are you [__]
though
you call me a [__] look i just got a
skin tag removed from my ass who did it
see that cut the dermatologist wow it
hurts though it's infected how did they
get rid of it
they they uh labeled it off
an electric thing yeah i thought i had
genital i thought i had a genital wart
on my ass
but it's a skin tag wait isn't it
is it a genital wart
he's got them all over on the genitals
no but genital warts spread here's a
phenomenon with genital warts this is a
phenomena
when or was it a phenomena or phenomenon
phenomenon
phenomenon so a phenomenon about genital
warts because you can get them on your
face one word phenomenon phenomenons you
can get them on your peepee but then
they can come out on your butt but it
doesn't mean you got anything on your
butt but they could just pop out
somebody else's
was near your butt
don't try to pretend like you don't know
how you got them back there wait if
someone has them on their pp and they
touch something they transfer from the
pp to the other thing yeah
that's how those work yeah how do you
get them in the first place you know
genital warts i i don't know h
p
v
that's it that's the cause human
papilloma virus we all have it we all do
have it i think a lot of people haven't
if you don't have hpv you ain't really
[__] right right right if you don't
have hpv you're just not someone i want
to know yeah give me hpv yeah you know
me now give me hpv yeah you know me who
[__] tonight who [__] at night you
got a hundred dollar bill with your
hands up you got a fifty dollar bills
or the garner sale all the goddess sales
be quiet
[Laughter]
yeah all right so you so you had to go
there and you did what would you do did
you pull just the cheek out that would
actually probably be like one of your
worst punishments sent on the joke is if
some if you your punishment was they
have you have to book a trip right now
and go
genital warts
you will you will you will
trip because that that's because i think
you're a very calculated you want a plan
which is great but i think if you tried
just try to do a trip not plan playing
see what happens just accepted we tried
uh for years and they kept denying us
doing it we might try it again but we we
pitched for years a punishment called a
bus to tampa we were gonna take one of
the guys and sit on a bus with them like
and then just
quickly hand cuff them to the seat and
then just get off and that bus was going
all the way to tampa and they just had
to literally sit on the bus we had the
bus like we're gonna have it camed up
and they just sat on the bus for the
entire ride to tampa and what about
eating or drinking or peeing now they
couldn't do any of it oh i didn't think
about that yeah that's probably why you
can't do it yeah are they going to piss
i didn't think about that well maybe the
point was that then when they got there
there was going to be another bus to
bring them back so we're going to have
to film it but we couldn't have a crew
so we got the company like rig up a
whole entire bus you could do like a bus
to baltimore and the alliteration helps
a lot bust the ball boston the bolt bus
the balti bus and then you don't need to
worry about pissing and eating yeah but
it's not three hour drive four hour
drive we wanted it to be excruciating
put something on the bus that makes it
worse okay this is okay did they have in
l.a are you looking for a writing job
i mean i'm i'm doing pretty good okay
yeah i know what i'm doing this guy's
going to sicily
bus lines remember bus lines in new york
absolutely
bus lines
let me tell you about this place
google
f-u-n-g hua w-a-h bus lines they would
go from any city's chinatown holy [__]
any anybody so new york city's chinatown
to
washington dc's chinatown to boston's
chinatown to baltimore any they would go
to from chinatown to chinatown for
1.99 was you could get a you can how do
you how is this megabus megabus did that
but this was but it was the precursor it
was fun bus lines but what's the
business model there it was only between
boston and new york that's it 96 of
2015. what was the price
and a brief period of 2014 it was shut
down for safety violations yes so they
would have so by they would have bus
drivers brief barriers
nobody nobody there were no um like two
dozen buses yeah you wouldn't have to
you wouldn't have to uh uh you know no
rules no union rules it was all chinese
immigrants coming over so they would
have them drive
at 40 hours in a row the buses were
discussing i took it to the boston
comedy festival once it was the most
nerve-wracking experience i'd rather
take fentanyl than get on fungua bus
lines well that's that's
2005 one of them caught fire 2006 they
one of them flipped over
07 uh lost two of its rear wheels
uh oh my god no oh seven uh hit a guard
rail on the turnpike
uh 07 again it got stuck in a concrete
box oh seven was a terrible fungus
2008 uh they were they're struck by a
dump truck
what's worse bus signs like the dump
truck i get now why it's 1.99 but no but
really though how do they sustain how is
that a business model i don't think it
was i think it was like probably like
some subsidizing there has to be
something it has to be some way to
sustain that business it can't it can't
be 1.99
i don't know yeah how did megabus do it
megabus did the same thing in europe i
took it when i was in europe i took
megabus from where i was staying in the
london and it had been it was i think it
was it was not it was 99 cents it was a
pound one pound to get to london and i
never understood how they did it i don't
even remember what it was maybe they
upcharged for the bathroom or something
or there was like
i don't remember what it was it's next
to free it is free like anyone i mean
literally a person that doesn't own a
home
anyone could get on it for a dollar how
long does it take to get to boston from
here three and a half hours so i guess
they figure if they if they can do three
and a half four hours do you think it
takes more than three and a half what
are you set at five no we're not what
are you leaving fridays at 4 p.m
[Laughter]
speak it up go right now boston 189
miles what does it say right now yeah
but but
right now three o'clock 249 250. four
hours and 21 minutes because it's 250.
okay go if you leave off time so you got
to leave off peak all right fair enough
you walk there in three days you can
walk you can hitch hike there and it
says hitchhike there a little bit faster
do you know could you imagine living in
ancient times where they would it was
very you would take a horse or walk from
new york to boston no problem
yeah that was the thing you know i'm
reading i'm watching this doctor i would
do that i would take a horse i would
take a horse and horse yeah you really
get to soak it up yeah a horse and
carriage no carriage i couldn't afford
to kill you just want a horse just the
whole kitchen the carriage is going to
slow you down a lot so much weight and
you got to bring something you have a
gallop on a horse you ever get to a
gallop speed on it i've been galloping
have you have you oh yeah what about you
i'm not in gal you know right now i just
got the skin tag i've galloped uh it is
scary yeah it's scary it's because the
sheer weight is bouncing up and down and
you look down you realize i'm eight feet
off the ground this thing wants to do
whatever you want to do with me got this
spinal cord injury because they got
thrown off the horse you think how does
that happen it's like because you said
he got it's like getting thrown off like
a
[__] first floor into the building we
went to a dude ranch on a class trip in
seventh grade i got on a horse the horse
started bucking i screamed the cow hand
came over the whole class got on horses
i was like one of the last ones and it's
jumping up and down and bucking and i'm
like help help cow guy comes over and he
goes well you [__] he goes you
[__] keep screaming it's gonna do it
even more he was such a dick
and i was like well he might have said
[__] him but he's like he truly had that
attitude he was like keep screaming you
think that's gonna help and i was i was
like 12 i'm a child yeah and then he
they put me on they got the oldest horse
they had they put me on that so i said
the horse just walked the whole thing
with all the hope and they went up the
trail my horse walked up to a tree just
started eating stuff off the tree and
would not move from the tree yeah that's
kind of nice yeah but that's kind of
nice you think that yeah it's nice you
know he wants to eat you can you you
bounce then you're not going to come to
a gallop he can't gallop
he can try no he can't he can drop he
can i like a skip i like a trotter or a
skip
gallivanting is nice i don't need a
really full heavy full speed horse
i like kind of sauntering around on a
horse i love the gallivant i love the
traipse i love the traipse if i said if
i said i'm in my vestibule what is where
where am i you're in a car
oh you think a vestibule is a car what
do you think if i'm in my vehicle like a
foyer yes a foyer you didn't a lot of
people don't know what a vestibule is
what is a vestibule a vestibule so like
when i would go down my house am i in
the front of your house like you know
like
but no not a foyer really okay okay okay
ready you're going into a bank right i'm
in it now i'm gonna open the door and
then there's like where the atm is then
you gotta open another door that's the
destination if you're all friends that's
an atm vestibule because chandler got
trapped in there with jill goodaker
harry connick's wife on an episode it
was a very special friend they got
trapped in between where the atm is and
the other and the outside of the
building yes it's an atm vestibule i
don't like that you don't like vestibule
why do i need it it's a fun word
i i like the word but why do i need the
space my father says
let me in like my dad he go and it's
just like you know say oh you know i
remember when he would tell me he would
like when i was still living with my mom
he'd call my mom and be like tell chris
i'm down in the vestibule and i'd go i'd
go meet him in the vestibule in my
apartment building and then that's the
lobby maybe lobby but then what he said
wouldn't you say lobby i'm in the front
of the building just like my dad said
come downstairs dad's very upset he goes
things like this he'll go he'll go go
like this he'll be like um you know if
we're at a yankees game he'd be like oh
do you want a frankfurter he won't say
hot dog because it's a hot dog hold on
like what he'll go up to somebody like
you guys have a men's room it's a
bathroom but isn't there a difference
between a frankfurter and a hot dog i
think there is i don't know what's the
difference i don't think those things
are the same i don't think anybody knows
now i think those things are true i mean
it was from frankfurt right frankfurt
germany
from hamburg germany yeah so that's
probably it was originally called a
frankfurter when and how did it get
dubbed a hot dog i think we've looked
this up before possibly some taste buds
questions yeah but frank footer is
different they have they like hot dogs
usually have little grill marks this way
frankfurters have little little
swastikas all the way down on the
frankfurter that's what i like that's
how you know it's different and the snap
is so much stronger on a frankfurter
yeah you can tell the bite is i know
when you when you bite the hunter goes
like this
it goes right up shoots right up you
know i was i'm watching this documentary
about benjamin franklin on apple tv by
ken burns which is amazing yeah i swear
to god
swear to god um uh you know imagine
franklin all these inventions that he
made all of them everything he every
invention he's made the the the
lightning rod the printing press all the
famous the yo-yo didn't patent any of
them mad libs because mad well no mad
libs we said was uh nietzsche
because he didn't believe
in patenting and making money he was
like my inventions are for the world are
for the people he wouldn't take any
money off his stupid
he is investing in him he's stealing his
company yeah come on he'll take his
company yeah and benjamin's like i'm i'm
offering this for whatever you think
appropriate
and they're like mr wonderful's like
i'll give you a grand for 94 percent
and he'll take the deal and he's like
yes
fight freedom for the people yeah
because a thousand dollars back then was
probably worth you know that's like 100
remember when we were little there was
those commercials that were like if you
have an invention call now oh yeah we'll
help you get your invention and that was
a whole big phishing scam it was a scam
you would sign that stuff and it would
be like that's exact it was like the
early shark tank yeah and they would
like but instead they would like i heard
the deals were terrible but people
sitting at home would just call up like
oh my god i have an invention i'm going
to get rich yeah and then they would do
this stuff and you're just giving a
company a good idea no oh they all you
do remember it right oh yeah because i
always used to be like oh my god i gotta
think of something inventors are you
invent yeah i remember it it was an
infomercial it was like a 1-800 number
yeah so my grandmother right she died
when i was a kid no she didn't she did
well maybe she's still uh i think yeah
she does she yeah she was i a kid yeah i
was like well maybe i was like an infant
she did let's bring her out grandma
grandma bring out her dead body look at
her she's on strings
hey chris
she wanted to talk about nazis this lady
was
she was dating and thought that he was
an idiot and said you're not your
business idea is not going to work she
was dating howard johnson no of howard
johnson's hotels
of the hotels howard johnson she was
like are you serious shout out hojo
shout out hojo she was like howard
johnson
she was like he's done like whatever and
they broke up when they were like 17. he
could have been dumb yeah because he she
thought he was just stupid and then she
started dating my grandfather who um
motel six no who cut his foot off he was
a garbage man he was a guardsman and he
cut his foot off on top of the garbage
you know what garbage men
back in the day
they would you know now we have they
crush the garbage back in the day was
just this big fan with blades and they
would drop the garbage on top of the
truck into the blades and guys would
fall through them all the time and my
grandfather cut his foot off and had to
be on disability for the rest of his
life because he got his foot caught in
the [__] garbage blade thing what a
stupid-ass idea of like your stock and
your lineage this makes so much yeah
it's just cutting the guy that would
yeah you come from a guy that would cut
his foot off in a garbage truck could
you imagine my grandpa was howard
johnson i wouldn't be me wow who would
you be now right i'd probably honestly
dude if my grandpa was howard johnson i
think i'd i'd be i'd honestly dude i'd
be like
who's like i like the like that reality
show that i'd be the gayest guy you
could ever meet and you're like who's
just beyond gay and flamboyant that's
who i'd be any of the guys from any of
the guys from the makeover show
that yeah the one we're talking about
the straight guy yeah the one with the
beautiful hair long hair jonathan
jonathan uh jonathan van ness
jonathan he does stand up you know that
oh no way i saw him chicago theater
he does stand up he does like he does
like a comedy uh act i did the paramount
austin when i was walking out margaret
it was at the festival moontown margaret
cho walked in with him
margaret shawn jimenez
walked in with jonathan van ness and i
was like okay that's it gets an odd oh
maybe he has a combo that's combo that's
a dual he didn't say hi to you no but he
didn't look at me
he didn't even know i was there did he
look you up and down he was wearing a
long coat
yeah very fashion forward yeah well lick
you up and down
do you say stop
let me play with your body baby make you
so hot
let me do
all the things you want me to do
cause tonight baby
i wanna get freaky with you
what do you think of that
i think pimp must be just miserable
why that's the clip listen you know it's
very very hard to find time i got to run
a business i got a family i got a
million things to do
and
ship station just makes it insanely easy
to just manage it all because i'm like
listen sometimes i'm like wait what am i
going to send out what do i get a mail
but ship station's always there it's
like your bff yeah if you run a business
and especially an online business and
you have to ship stuff this basically
calls everything together in one
platform gives you the best rates yeah
and you can use it to for efficiency you
don't have to i mean it's all done
at home yeah at home and that's why ship
stations trusted by over 100 000 sellers
98 of companies that use ship station
for a year keep using it for as long as
they're in business so you know this
stuff works out in your pipeline okay
put that in your pipe and smoke it and
then mail it actually yeah you know ship
stations
put down your pipe and mail it put that
in your pocket and ship it put that in
your pipe and ship it there you go
that's we found i think that's new
merchants
that is new merch
ship station right now if you go to
shipstation.com i mean deep discount
rates deeply discounted rates you're
better off doing ship station than going
to your fedex and your ups and all right
shipstation.com that's that's
shipstation.com
promo code hey babe for a free
60-day trial that's two months 60 days
free
shipstation.com promo code hey babe that
is two whole months of shipping made
quick and painless and you can compare
the carriers the rates the delivery
times all right there in front of you
and pick the best solution every single
time for your shipment needs ship
station make ship happen
fresh from san diego california san
diego milk was a bad choice comes the
only glasses brand sunglasses brand i'm
ever gonna wear again i'm never gonna
wear anything i know that you like them
that is some serious that's a serious
throwdown blender's eyewear is the only
type of sunglasses you ever see on my
face you're gonna be just as hooked when
you see how awesome the shades are they
got all sorts of different styles and
colors and all right perfect pimples
wearing blend as i wear the uh just the
other day i saw him i was like where you
got those glasses like dude blenders and
you know pimp is great looks great with
glasses yeah you know pimp's style and
you know that pimp is up on it and if
pimp's wearing blenders then that's all
you need to know about blender because
unlike expensive big brand shades that
you probably lost or smashed in the past
blenders are actually affordable so
you're not going to cry as much when the
inevitable happens which is you broke
and lost your glasses chase fisher the
starter had a vision and it was to
create adventurous mid-priced eyewear
options with the same cool factor as the
big expensive boys hell yeah and
blender's team of in-house designers are
constantly coming out with new styles
from orange polaroid rapper polarized
wrap-arounds tortoise shell frames with
purple lenses the classic gold arms or
black lenses blenders are not just
sunglasses it they have subscription
glasses readers and blue lights they got
everything goggles so right now to get
15 off your blender's purchase go to
blenders blenderseyeware.com and enter
the promo code hey babe vip that's
blenderseyewear.com
code hey babe vip for 15 off blenders
rock with pride worldwide
know it yeah
i wanted to sit back and let you guys do
it yourself relax hit the contacts
sit back relax and let yourself go don't
fret what you heard and act like you
know yes yes all right
yes
i got to tell you something this girl
was listening to a uh uh was listening
to
in the studio i was just at she was just
she just put on like a you know just
like a mix of music and i was like oh
what a [__] song and it was the
edited or the clean version
and i was like
it was any [__] hip-hop song i don't
even know what it was it was like a
newer hip-hop song yeah but i was like
the clean version no
i was like why is that what are you
doing and she's like what do you mean i
was like they're cussing out
yeah they blank out all the cuss words
and she was like oh i didn't notice i
was like yeah you did
yeah there's how do you
what of course you any hip-hop song if
you blank if you blank out the n-word
and the cuss words you notice
it's impossible not to notice right
any snoop dog song go ahead name one go
ahead dude sometimes they drop it out
but sometimes they put a a different
word in it yeah yeah what's this
what's um chicken juice
yeah
go ahead sing a lyric from gin and juice
um
better eat a big fat sandwich sam
hot dog frankfurter yeah easy eat kitty
the big fat friend
juice
that's the chorus all right go ahead i
know my money i'm i don't know any other
i don't know now i got me some juice in
gin everybody got their cups but they
ain't chipped in you see this type of
[__] this type of stuff yes happens all
the time
you gotta get yours before i gotta get
mine
everything is fine when you listen to
the dog i got the captivating music that
be cultivated me
who listens to the words that i speak
yeah
when i take me a drink from this cup
ministry i get the pack of those [__]
names this lady named satan lady oh
sorry this lady named boys
please raise up off these
genitals
uh you get none of these at ease
as i roll with the dog pound feel the
breeze uh
no no you can't go [__] you can't go
[__] i'm just yesterday you would say
a powerful woman powerful woman i'm just
right that's right whenever you have a
hardcore friend that's a feminist if
she's a hardcore feminist ask if she
likes hip hop
because they don't like her yeah yeah
yeah you cannot be a hardcore feminist
people every [__] song is by the way
so many female comedians on twitter
because george clyne documents you watch
that george carlin documentary i did and
i didn't i i watched it on the airplane
i fell asleep i woke up to a part i fell
asleep i woke up to a party i loved i've
done that but all these all these women
all these i see a lot of female comics
out there they're like we need george
god's like george carlin back well you
know he
hated feminism he was like this is the
dumbest thing of all time he was like
you know he couldn't care less about it
but i hate i will say all of those all
those jokes are back then people are
doing now today it's so funny it's the
exact same stuff he's doing abortion gun
stuff you're like man it's the exact
same jokes yeah
people do them today he was so good well
the things his life was so good and then
by the end it was [__] weirdish well
when i like then he got dark well what i
liked about george carlin what i didn't
know was like you know he's he's twice
yeah he's known for you know 14 hbo
specials that's like what comics think
of you know his first hbo hour special
he was already 45 years old he didn't do
an hour the whole idea of an hour of
comedy wasn't a thing until like hbo
started doing i mean eddie murphy's ron
whatever but carlin didn't do and won
his very first because he had had a
heart attack at a dodgers game a dodgers
mets game that's right he had a heart
attack and then he had this whole new
lease on life he was like i got to start
turning out material and then he started
and then he would do an hour a year an
hour every two years he said his comedy
got easier for him as he got older my
buddy's brother just had a heart attack
at 38 years old healthy dude healthy guy
physical therapist had a heart attack i
called him up because i ran into a
friend of a friend who said did you hear
what happened to so-and-so i said no we
said i had a heart attack i said get the
[__] out of here dude he's in the best
shape he's a physical therapist he goes
he is i called his brother i said dude
your brother a heart attack he goes yeah
did you hear what happened to my dad i
said well he goes a month before my
brother had a [__] heart attack my
parents are visiting the grandkids we go
into the pacific ocean my dad has to
swim everywhere we go he has to swim he
goes out there and swims the mother goes
where's your dad he's i don't [__]
know he's out there looks out there he's
upside down his dad is out in the water
no get this he [__] saved his own
dad's life
hand to god you're kidding he gets in
the water pulls his father out he's
doing chest compressions on him and
they're getting water out of him so
people are screaming coming to [__]
help him out he's like dude i blacked
out adrenaline was [__] slamming his
chest the water came out his dad is
alive oh my [__] and he had a heart
attack at 38 a month later no his
brother little brother did he saved his
father then his brother had a 38 year
old heart attack did he pass no all both
are alive oh my god both are alive this
[__] family it's like they can't kill
these [__] people yeah it's like
what's that what's that movie where they
you avoid death what what what oh um
i think about that all the time when i
get on the highway behind a truck that
has a bunch of [__] in it i'm almost
like something's gonna come yeah the
[__]
the [__] screw is
yeah exactly right through my [__]
forehead i always feel that way
i merge i get out of the way every time
so i got so i and my daughter in the car
this is when my oldest daughter who's
seven now she was maybe like three and
she's in the car i swear to god she was
fine no she wasn't
you don't know what [__] age she was
she was four okay fine she was four i
can't wait to find out your daughter's
like 26. i know you just have no idea i
know or she's not she's not my daughter
shout out showing the contractor so
if you're listening and we know that
yeah so so anyway so i was on the
manhattan bridge right and same thing
there was a truck behind me that had
stuff on it and my daughter was
terrified she was like no i'm so scared
whatever so i was like all right baby so
i whizzed around the truck and i gunned
it till like 80 just to get past his
truck right past the cop pull me over
whoa take it so then
yeah
a child a cop
a little boy
what sound does a cow make
[Laughter]
so i say to the to the judge because you
know you go and like defend yourself i
go listen i was like i you know he was
like well how do you explain yourself
driving this fast and i said
with all due respect i said your honor i
think you do the same thing to me i said
i cause he was like you were going 85
miles an hour in a 35 mile per hour zone
on a bridge he was like i should take
your license away for that and i was
like with all due respect your honor i
said i had my infant daughter in the
back seat makes it worse and she was
well that's what i said and she was
scared and she was scared of the truck
in front of me so in an effort to you
know make sure she wasn't afraid and
safe i gunned past the truck because
when i got when the truck you know were
on uh when the truck was parallel to me
she was scared that the truck was gonna
fall on her so i sped up to get past it
i thought to put my child out of danger
he goes so let me get this straight
you you thought and you first of all he
goes i didn't know your child was in the
back seat he goes and he goes did you
think that detail was going to make this
better for
you right away right away he goes let me
stop me for a second son yeah did your
grandfather lose his foot in a garbage
truck
it was so because you know it was so
funny because when you go to appear in
court i'm sure it's the same everywhere
you know the police officer who gave you
the ticket also appears to give a story
when i'm saying that my daughter was in
the back seat i swear to god i saw the
car i saw the cop go like this
he's going like this he's like even he's
like
you know what i would have said though
you [__] up you done [__] up yeah
you know you're done [__] up
i would have said the truck was swerving
there was only two lanes i was really
scared that this thing was gonna side
swipe me so in an effort to get out of
the way of it swerving i went really
fast so i could clear the truck he
almost hit me yeah your honor he was
driving erratically yeah it was
disgusting yeah and you know these guys
they're on pills these [__] truckers
are getting ahead from [__] from
[__]
tramps from truck stops
like i understand yeah and you're like
let me go off i would have said go let
me off my kid is still in the car and
the windows are closed another
thing a little trickeroo you postpone
postpone until the cows come home so
they allow you to postpone twice each
time you plus one it's a year i postpone
a ticket i swear to god for seven well i
supposed to own it twice and then they
postponed it five more times it was
seven years later it was a cell phone
ticket 25 dollars no when it was the
points is what i was worried about is
when i got hit with yeah and so and so
i mean i'm not exact it was seven years
later i had hired a guy to go you could
hire the lawyer they say most likely
have to pay the fee they'll get the
points taken away so i had this guy on a
retainer for like five years and every
every year on the date they'd send me an
email and be like
they postponed it again and then after
seven years that [__] cop didn't show
and i got away got away with it no take
it off no tick as long as the cop does
yeah but i got i had to my my ticket
went from 200 to 550 and i got three
points taken off of my license but then
i took a defensive driving course which
you have to pay eight hundred dollars
for and then you get the points back but
scam there i know somebody who could
give those out for a fee
really yeah i didn't hear it here but i
know somebody who will take some money
and print out that cert and you don't
have to take the course but you didn't
hear it here but i don't know that
person but i know a person but i don't
know that person but if i knew that
person wouldn't that be a cool thing
that would be a cool thing yo if you
wanna yeah so you don't know that person
i don't condone that because it's not
real but if it was real and you could do
it let me know i'll put you in touch
with them but i don't know that person
but
i got all those guys yeah right you got
i'll admit it i got a guy that'll sell
you a fake fax card still really you
really do have that business is down for
him
it's just not the same wow they just now
you that's what you should get he's
begging for him booster he's begging for
something to come out that we got it i
know because monkey pox ain't it it's a
stupid name nobody tries about monkey
box took a good swing they got a couple
they said they said you can cure it with
the other shot for something else they
said yes yes yes like a cancer shot yeah
a monk epoxy they developed like a
cancer a cancer shot and it made it go
away which stinks because i wanted
monkeybox to kind of show its fangs i
wanted to see what it could really do
yeah you know because it was going to
sweep through new york of all places
it's coming here you know it's coming
here well they said it's prevalent in
the gay community from um that's enough
chris it's pride fun
why do you do that i'm telling you the
truth it's the pride month and this
guy's got to step on them every single
thing now damn dude
we love butcher box yo i love butcher
box book your booktubebox is a
subscription service where you could
choose the most prime cuts of chicken
meat poultry fish and get it sent right
to your door you could choose from boxes
that they have you can customize a box
you could pause the cancel anytime you
get 14 pounds of meat up in that son of
a gun and uh i mean you don't have to go
to the store you have to worry that you
i want to cook something tonight oh we
got to go to the store and get it no
it's right there in the freezer all the
time
you got 100 grass fed beef free range
organic chicken wild caught seafood
which i love love seafood and every
month butcherbox ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your caribola so you can get summer
sizzling starting with the special butch
box butch box deal butcher box deal for
our listeners free bacon for life dude i
i mean
of your membership plus 10 all you got
to do is go to butcherbox.com
hey babe use the code hey babe to get
one pack of free bacon in every box for
the life of your membership plus ten
dollars off your order you're getting
money and banking save yourself time
save yourself money
butcherbox.com hey babe and use code hey
babe to claim this deal free bacon
what's your box
you know what this podcast you know what
this podcast is sponsored by better
helping more help
better help
help just want to let everyone know yeah
better help because listen everyone's
getting burnt out you know it's it's a
thing that's plaguing us all if we turn
the camera just a couple of degrees this
way you will see what one joe derosa and
he is burnt down
and he's got to get on with better look
there he is better help is your friend
babe connect to an online therapist in
under 48 hours uh
joe derosa said he said you know what
instead of using better help i'm just
going to go up the street and eat thai
food and it was the wrong choice he
should have had a session with better
help because guess what it could be done
all online over zoom or over the phone
you don't have to go anywhere you can do
it wherever you are and these are
licensed uh uh therapists and guidance
counselors that will help you get right
prioritize yourself for once all day
every day we're on the go go go we're
putting everything in front of ourselves
betterhelp wants us to take a minute
stop and prioritize yourself and get
yourself right now your our listeners
right now can get 10 off their first
month at
betterhelp.com hey babe that's better
h-e-l-p-com hey babe get 10 off your
first month and because what better help
is it just just so we can clarify it is
a customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you don't have to leave the house and
you don't have to see anybody that's
that's never been done before never and
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours so as we
said where can they where can they get
the discount 10 all to our listeners for
the first month at betterhelp.com hey
babe
betterhelp.com hey babe we love you
better help every single thing are you
going to the pride parade because i am
you where i did last year on the float
yeah
the bar store the most fun day ever by
the way the bar still floating yeah
okay okay what is it what is it for
homophobes no i swear yeah
what's his name i saw him in the street
the other day i was leaving barcelona
and he kept me he's like i just was like
crazy but that wasn't really how he
sounded but in my head it was joey
god bless him
nobody over there joey would love you no
there's a show the gay show on barcelona
one day one cause the rest of that thing
is so [__] i don't know i know i saw
it yesterday yesterday i said bro bro
you walk in they chant bro
i know yesterday there was like a you
what do you see there was like a u-haul
van full of white supremacists that got
caught they were going to the pride a
pride parade in like the middle of the
country it was 30 guys that got inside
of you all right there was 27 of us but
they they did
well i was going to say that's i want to
i tweeted who showed up but i guess
nobody showed up
yeah we got hit it was nuts you got to
get off that [__] thing the wheels
fell off
wait they were in a u-haul though why
not just rent a van i know dummies wait
they put themselves in the back of the
u-hole yes they rented you and they all
had like assault weapons they were going
to go to some like
middle america pride parade here's what
someone needs to do some some genius
some evil genius needs to needs to be to
pretend to be this like great leader of
white supremacists and be like we're
meeting in this group the greatest
meeting of all time we're going to do
january 6 again and have them meet
somewhere and then we just ambush kill
them all yeah
why wouldn't we do that why would we
dude this country used to used to live
on like spies and espionage and amazing
trickery espionage is one of my favorite
words i love it almost as much as
dungarees hungary
why can't we have someone who's a genius
trick everyone into doing that and then
we kill all those [__] you
could well why don't we do the guys
those three i know but they have rights
unfortunately as well dude no no
nobody's got rights no what they do it's
a civil thing which ironic but george
carlin's going back george clooney kill
him anyway i believe that
i believe it
george carlin's holding renegade stuff
how come there's not a renegade
i love when they caught him saying the
n-word they're like can you believe it
you're like did you see photos
yeah you're like [__] can you believe
this is the best word that guy looks
like he teaches it to people
here's how you say it
he's got some tan though never seen him
out of ten he'd never not been in the
sun it's unbelievable he's a ruthless
house yeah yeah he's ruthless how does
he not have skin cancer he didn't mind
dead now no is he dead is he dead no dr
bounty hunter ain't dead we would've had
an episode in memoriam yeah yeah
is he no he's not he's he's alive and
kicking is he oh yeah but his wife beth
beth is my hero love beth love me a good
beth oh what's she what's she about
she's dating someone new now she's free
you know after the whole thing she got
she got freed is that true i really
don't know anything about this out in
the streets wow that's down the streets
hitting no sheets
he's alive his daughter passed away
what happened puppy puppy the body party
i had no idea about that
sorry what happened i'm not sure there's
like a eight-minute video of him you
know he's got something he's like she
was killed you don't eat a little grinch
you know it's tragic yeah i don't know
that's very sad i hope that's very sad
i'm sorry for her and god bless you know
who died remember that guy remember that
guy
steve irwin died um by the way hoax
really alive he just didn't want to do
that [__] anymore he got sick of it
interesting you imagine all that
energy's like crikey it's so crazy what
i'm doing with this
and then when the cameras are down he's
like he's smoking it's dark he's like i
can't [__] do this i can't do it
anymore the accent is fake i can't like
we can't play this thing anymore yeah
yeah and we're like what do you want to
do
he said he got stuck he the way he died
is he got shot through the heart by a
stingray dart i'm like yeah okay so sad
his son does it now you know that
yeah his son is him he's doing things
dude so in the same bit
i thought stingrays couldn't hurt you
they killed sting man or manta rays
don't have stingers or barbs on them or
teeth i just swam with them you know
when you go
wow no stingrays do have barbed barbed
tails and also teeth oddly enough manta
rays or ghost race who's another one
that we saw
can't hurt you they come right after you
swim right now yeah yeah you're not
trying to because it [__] up the
ecosystem are you serious manta rays
manta rays yes stingrays put it in the
name they put in the name they like you
like jacques cousteau well traveled a
little bit
you know who he knows you know he knows
a good friend of the show patrick
mahomes
oh
shout out shut up shut up
if we didn't mention them well we got
him maddie patty moe's my guy love that
guy we just wanna play golf in hawaii
that's how i got to swim and we went out
there and i'm not kidding the guy was
like you guys want to go uh you guys
want to go scuba snow and snorkel in the
morning and pat was like let's all go so
10 of us went in the thing we go out
there about three 400 yards out and dude
you're out out you're out out out there
there's no cage no net no nothing and he
goes all right you get ready we jump in
the [__] water i put i put on my
[__] i put on my mask and i look down
i mean the clear i mean it's so
beautiful [__] clear it is it's about
30 40 feet down that's how [__] clear
did you see the bottom yeah this dude
this local dude was the [__] he
literally was like i'm gonna go down bro
see what i can see he'll swim down and
hold his breath and be at the bottom for
no [__] two minutes straight no [__]
just still with a spear gun because he
wanted to catch uh uh mahi-mahi and he
comes back up he goes no fish because he
wanted to sashimi them on the boat he
goes no fish but you want to see a shark
and i was like
do i want to see a shark yes he goes
yeah he lives here he lives here he's
here all the time i said okay he swims
down we're all [__] looking i i'm not
kidding he he coerces him out of the
cave like this i'm not kidding it comes
right out swims right around his body
and he points up at us like a king of
the [__] sea like look what i've
bestowed to you right and we're all just
bubbling up at the top and you can hear
people going
like aquaman couldn't believe it like
he's amber swam around him and then he
pushed her pushed the shark i mean like
guided her right back into that's
[__] crazy and i said it's like a
hard one i said what happens if it's
having a bad day he's like then it's my
last day in the ocean
didn't give a [__] like that's something
that is
for sure guess what patrick mahomes
calls himself during pride month what
patrick mahomosa
what's up man this has been hey babe
[Laughter]
zooming on his face
you know you can't i'm talking to you
you can't talk about my homes without
shouting out tom brady because you guys
should have time to
in the super bowl a couple years ago at
tampa uh and tom plays for tampa and
he's the oldest guy in the nfl and he
won a super bowl he did win a super bowl
you know but you got to give it up for
patrick mahomes and that club over there
because they're up and coming and
they'll be back and then they won the
first team to win the super bowl in uh
in their hometown
yeah how do you know patrick mahomes
and uh because i know travis kelsey i
met him we were gonna do a project
together and we never really did it we
came buddies and then
travis kelsey was on my other show the
misery index he's the man nice guy he's
a very nice guy they're great dude
they're great kansas city got a good
group of guys then people online are
like you're a [__] bears fan you're
posting with like kansas city [__] you
know how to do that and it's like hey
man when you grow up when you grow up
you you realize that you can also
support people like you know i learned
that from my dad i learned from myself
so my dad look let me tell you we're die
hard cubs fans we've always been my
whole life
my dad's one of his very best friends
his father is a white as a hall of famer
for the chicago white sox okay he has a
statue in left center field right we go
to sox games i throw we'll throw on a
socks hat for them and support them if
they're playing each other a different
story yes but if we go there to support
we're supporting someone we love and
know yes so
when that dude interfered with the catch
steve bartman yeah how did you feel
about that not a big deal not his fault
really that wasn't that city turned on
the final game anyway first of all
because the city is filled with [__]
[__] goomba weirdo morons that wasn't
the [__] deciding game anyway and we
had two other errors outside of that
right that already [__] up the game
right here's this guy this great guy
he's an idiot he's an idiot but he's a
great guy reach over i'm reaching i'm
looking you see it coming you don't know
what's going on did you see this
because he went like this this this and
slapped his glove and that's what made
him excited he excited if he just walked
away yeah no one would have ever thought
one of the biggest types of losers you
can be
losers you can be is the guy
who will get physical over defending his
sports team did you see the rangers the
rangers got hit do you know what an
[__] you dude nobody on the rangers
they would step over your burning
[__] body
to get to the next game they don't if
you're a die-hard fan of a sports team
that's great that's beautiful but if
you're ever going to get physical or not
talk to someone because they don't like
your team i can't describe to you what a
[__] loser or a young guy you have
zero going on in your life
that guy that punch out lightning
physical physical i wanna get physical
let's get into physical let me hear your
body talk
your body i know none of these lyrics
are physical i can't believe you know so
many more
oh i want to get animal she says that
after and by the way animals yeah by the
way that's a i mean that's a song to
play with i was just singing that [__]
we were talking about i used to think
that [__] at the top of my left hand i
know no idea what about tournaments
today because i was on the reddit you
know that song move into the country
gonna eat a lot of peaches
it's about [__] it's about eating [__]
i didn't know that that's yeah what do
you mean i knew that you didn't know
that i didn't know that peaches
traditionally though refers to ass yeah
but not but that's just cause the emoji
that wasn't an emoji before that a peach
was a puss yeah peaches puss and an ass
was an apple i guess millions of peaches
peaches for me millions of peaches
peaches for free because he was a
rockstar he didn't pay for so much he
didn't pay for it
let me see that kiwi girl really yeah
it's fun i say compassion fruit i say
let me see a little piece
of passion let me see i said let me see
that banana you have oh what is that
banana let me see that banana she'd be
like i pull on my dick she's like why do
you have grapes on your dick i'm like
it's genital warts
you have a pomegranate dick
pomegranate
seeds
best thing you do food processor eating
some pomegranate it's really really good
hundred percent had a prostate exam yet
yes you have
i beat me and a buddy and i we do it all
yeah yeah yeah no i just i just haven't
did you really i haven't had one yet i'm
not a little bit uh i got it i got it
can i tell you something yeah so [__]
easy there's this weird you feel a lot
of pressure in your [__] though so
what to
do you have a relationship with a person
who did it to you
like is that your long-standing doctor
or is that a woman you don't have a
urologist on call so you're a guy you
don't know this guy you just show up and
then everyone knows i don't know i do
know this guy i know mine i actually do
really yeah because i had chronic
prostatitis i used to get did you find
them on hotel tonight i thought is it
are we plugging that now they better
sponsor this show they better talk about
it in 20 minutes sorry no i had a
chronic prostatitis a couple years ago
like five six years ago you know what
that is no i do know what chronicles
bph painful under under here you're
undercarriage your gooch your nipkin
your no-fly zone yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was painted sharpies right up my
taint yeah and wow dude a little bph
i've been in i said what's going on what
could this be
and of course you're like like what what
what the [__] what like what's going on
it's not like it wouldn't be your
instinct is that worst fear well you're
not like it's your instinct isn't std
you don't go to that because it's not
penis related it's inside underneath
right so i was scared how did you deal
with this did you say
a couple years
yeah chronic prostatitized it kept
coming and going it was undiagnosed
in the prostate well no i would it would
go away it comes and it goes so i then
went in finally he did a prostate exam
and he's like there's things you can do
but unfortunately like the prostate is
so
um
medicine medicine doesn't get to it
doesn't get into it
because too deep in your body he's like
and we're trying to still figure out
over the years what's going to make this
you know he's got pain relievers but
he's like to fix this is really hard so
i would take different stuff for
different antibiotics sometimes i was
like i don't want to take antibiotics
right and he's like but you got to try
one of these what causes it it's a
million different things it could be
bacteria synthromax is probably the one
you you were given cipro cipro ciprox
yeah because cipriani uh because uh uh
uh it can be bacteria in there it can be
uh just the way your your prostate
hello
puppy dog
is jewish is that okay hello
whose dog is this ari shapiro is that
okay oh [__] really you
a know jewish puppy dog or this is our
this actually is ours this is justin
silver
what a sweet [__] dog what a sweet
little dog
tell us about your prostitute bandit
bandit you son of a [__] little son of
a [__] bandit now banter are you in
black face what's going on well he's
half black face
half black half white face looks like a
cow all due respect history oh sorry
well i don't see gender but yeah it's
fine let me see that key we banned it
so i don't know so my
worst fear is if you go in there yeah
and then like did you sit in the waiting
room and you got to check in with
everyone before that person and then
when you get in there and they ask you
to drop and they put on it's just like
look you got to you got to put in your
head that they do this this is like an
assembly line they're not thinking that
like they're fingering yes
that and a colonoscopy i'm very i'm very
you never got a colonoscopy either no no
i got them both i can't talk to them am
i in a danger zone no well colonoscopy
they put you out yeah you're getting
close how old are you now four or five
got to do it guys you got to do it got
to do it that jordan i got mine at 35.
when jordan came back that's what he
said that's that was a prostate that was
a prostate colonoscopy number you've
gotten both of those
yeah a colonoscopy is probably worth it
you're young you young son prostate yeah
but i had to check it out because
because of that because of the [__]
prostate
colonoscopy put something up there and
what happens you get put to sleep for
that though colonoscopy
and they blow like a balloon
no no no they fill you up get put to
sleep and then what happens in there
they know they know what they think you
know there's professionals that like in
the room when they're just there they're
doing something they're just [__]
around yeah they're [__] right
they put a what they do is how you're
putting this penis in different
positions yeah they put a camera up your
ass and there's a camera at the end of
the thing and then they sneak around
yeah my yeah my
you can choose too like um choose your
own adventure choose you could get also
get an endoscopy at the same time
through the mouth and through the ass
and then the same time they they meet
and they don't like them at the same
damn time yeah what is this record for a
dream what's going on no they could just
one they could just it's easier that way
you just get scoped you get scoped and
um scoped and poked it's golden pope
and then you can do it on ig live too
i immerse you did it
and you get put out and then you wake up
do you feel weird
no you you get put it's it's local it's
like when you're walking out like thanks
guys like you don't know you don't see
it you don't say thank you ever you
don't no it says on the wall it's like
do not thank the okay so i'll tell you
what when i i i i woke up i came too and
then jasmine don't say that
i can't i when i woke up jasmine
had my phone
in her hand and i was like i just like
woke up like that
just my ass oh she got to stay there
yeah
well she somebody has to come pick you
up a viewing window you can watch it all
go down okay yeah some people buy
tickets to it and she and she you know
she goes she's like i'm like waking up
and i'm like is it over and she goes
yeah and she goes now your nightmare is
about to begin and she has the phone
like that and she was like i'm just
[__] with you everything's fine i was
like oh and then uh that's the nice
thing to do yeah i know i was like
thanks and then and then and then the
doctor and then the doctor he goes so
funny he goes you're fine he goes we
found a couple of polyps he goes we
found a couple of problems but they're
they're going to be fine but don't worry
about it but nine by nine he said
they're going to be fine and then i
remember i went right across the street
and i had um uh uh because you can't eat
for 12 hours before you got to take this
medicine where you just i mean
everything on your balance is about
around like jackson polyps jacks of
polyps
you you the thing is that the hardest
thing for you will be is the pre-drink
because you literally i had to wear a
diaper in the cab going to
the thing because i was still my ass was
still leaking
i think i honestly just rolled the dice
i don't think i'm gonna do it
i don't think i'm gonna put on a diaper
show up at the place and just put me to
sleep and go and everything yeah you get
a new five out of it yeah you do get a
new feature that is actually very true
you do but it is it is it is an
interesting interesting thing we should
all get especially with our our diets
are all american diets are so low and
fiber we missed you last night by the
way i know i couldn't come because after
dinner it was beautiful i know it was so
[__] wonderful it was such a great
night we went out to dinner we had a
great [__] meal sal god bless you had
[__] took care of the bill like a
like a champ
didn't have to do it didn't even have to
do it yeah he did it and it was just
like what are you doing and he just he
was doing he's just a generous sweet
prince and then we went to see ari do
his hour it was such a nice what did you
do after that huh what'd you do after
that we hung out in the basement and
just chilled with ari and had some
scotch and we talked [__] he was so nice
he was with us with us well thank you
christy o'connor was there brian sick
and i got to tell you something
at one point
ari goes
where's the stefano and i said not a
committed friend i know
no i know a
no you're not though and i know you're
not because you even said it might even
send the text i'm not sorry
sorry not sorry sorry i'm not sorry
we'll cook a hotel on the fly but you
can't go to a friend you can't go to
your friend's room should i get it i get
special tonight
you know what's funny is i literally
there is i'm shooting my special tonight
app for all comedians
i was literally thinking about you guys
i was like oh [__] i wish i was that ari
special but instead i was ironing my
daughter's school uniform that's what i
was doing like a [__] ironing my
daughter's school uniform what did you
go to catholic school yeah good you good
for you god bless hell yeah dude yeah
catholics will on staten island as a
matter of fact one of the color this is
this is the thing with gender how racist
are the is that that's filled with this
this is 2022. my daughter's school they
came home with a coloring you know kids
learn coloring you know activities
whatever what does a man do what does a
woman do public schools are doing this
and that my school this present day
america came home with two sheets one of
a man wonderful wouldn't color it in the
man had a hammer to a wall and the woman
was in uh an apron with a broom that's
what men and women's jobs are
my fault
what men and women do i was like yes i
know you said the man had a hammer and
the woman was going like this
where could people see it santino i'm
i'm done i'm done touring i'm going to
shoot a special in a couple of months i
think i think i hope but i'm done
touring man this is my last run i did
buffalo i did jersey and i said i'd give
the long kiss goodnight i can't wait to
put this material to bed
daddy's done and then i'm gonna shoot
season three and dave so i'm gonna be
doing nothing for a little while i'm
going hopefully going to italy and then
uh i don't know come see watch me oh
actually when does this come out soon
yeah uh next two weeks july 7th oh july
7th damn that's so far away all right
well it already happened i was gonna
promote we're doing a bad friends live
we're doing a live stream bad friends
and we're having all these crazy fun
surprises but it'd have already happened
it happened uh june 28th and then bobby
killed himself the next day he did he's
gone thank god
yeah he's gone no that little he's so
good my little my little dumpling is the
best dude i love him so much he walked
out last night of um
he walked out of uh the new jurassic
park and i got a text late last night
from a guy in la that we know and bobby
doesn't really know him and he goes
bobby walked out of jurassic park
i go why and how do you know that he
goes i was sitting two rows behind him
but he didn't he doesn't recognize me or
know me
i texted bobby i said i heard i heard
you walked out of jurassic park
he goes how the [__] do you know that
and he i he's having i said this guy
that we know was at the thing and he
goes worst movie i've ever seen in my
[__] life tell everyone
i won't go see
see it tonight i said this
tonight i was going to top it on address
yeah yeah i heard top gun is phenomenal
do you want to see the first top gun
i've never seen the first top gun it's
been a while but i've seen you saw when
it happened yeah it's what it is baby
you know what that you know what the
whole top gun is about right no it's an
unrequited like gay love story it's a
it's like a guy who can't come out you
don't know this that's what they say it
is yeah it is didn't know that boys of
summer uh that girl hit him in that
check what's her name what was her name
this is like weird unrequited love it's
like not supposed to happen guess what
you said it's about a guy that can't
come out you're ready for this that's
what we'll get off on you know what it
should be called instead of top gun
top bottom bottom gun
it wasn't it's been hidden we tried it
[Music]
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe